at the end of season six of The Walking
Dead a new mysterious villain named
negan played by jeffrey dean morgan
stood above the cast of heroes but who
is this highly charismatic villain
standing in the way of the fine folks of
Alexandria we're taking a look at his
comic book counterpart to give you a bit
more insight into who negan is and what
he wants in life number five negan cares
about those closest to it before the
outbreak when he was a high school coach
negan swype developed cancer even though
he was in the midst of an affair he
stayed with his wife right after the
Walker outbreak he was ordered to leave
the hospital but wanted to spend every
moment with her right up until her death
number four Megan's weapon of choice
isn't a typical one it's a baseball bat
wrapped in barbed wire named Lucille if
that's not damaging enough at one point
during the comics he covered the bat in
Walker guts to make it more deadly the
bat is named after his late wife that's
a bizarre way to remember your loved
ones number three whenever negan meets a
new group of people he kills one of them
off to show everyone that he means
business this happened during Megan's
first appearance an issue 100 of the
walking dead comic and it will be the
focus of the season 7 premiere this year
in addition to keep order within his own
ranks he will sometimes burn his own
men's faces with a hot iron hum dee
what do I you can call me the number to
negan is the leader of the Savior's but
we saw quite a bit in season six of the
AMC series in the comic the group came
to power after striking a deal with the
hilltop to remove the walkers in the
area in turn they gave the Savior
supplies from the town the group then
worked their way to other communities
ruling through fear number one while we
may never see the story on the AMC
series megan has a bizarre relationship
with Carl Grimes at one point in the
comment Carl kills off a group of the
Savior's and wants to kill negan the
charismatic leader of the group forms a
bizarre bond with Carl as Megan sees a
lot of himself in this young man for
more TV movies and walking dead keep it
here to gamespot universe yeah we can
just turn these people inside out I mean
the ones that are left